[Music]
ted is standing by gorgeous today it's
going to be even better tomorrow warmer
so it's really a fantastic couple of
days i understand the last
this past weekend not so much no i know
you were out of town but this weekend we
had wind on wednesday denise's groceries
went everywhere she was telling us about
that
where'd they end up but here's the deal
tomorrow looks great but i wish it could
last
because we have changes come wednesday
67 are high for the day today
nice all right 64 is where we should be
so we're above average we jumped into
the 60s again
40 overnight for the low i think
tomorrow we're going to be in the 70s
warmest day
this week is going to be tomorrow sky
canyon 63 for you right now that
includes also
centennial hills at 56 or actually 60 in
centennial hills right now 66 for north
las vegas
68 sunrise manor whitney ranch at 68
degrees 61 anthem mountains edge 65.
low 60's for you and henderson right now
so very comfortable outside
all across the region 62 for prompt nice
in boulder city at 60 even in laughlin
you're currently at 68 degrees down in
southern clark all right satellite and
radar again this is both the satellite
radar combined you can see some echoes
coming back
way over the pacific northwest dry here
clear skies throughout the state
here now we're eyeing the chances for
showers to return but it's just not
going to happen here with that first
front
that's going to push through it
typically what happens is you'll get
some moisture ahead of a cold front not
behind it
because that's a cold dense air but
lately we just haven't seen any so
looks like we'll remain dry again we're
watching saturday and sunday this has a
little bit of promise to it
but it looks like most of it will stay
in the central and northern part of our
state while
we remain dry right now but we will get
breezy winds to return
again for the weekend even windy on
saturday tonight 47 degrees mostly clear
and chilly
winds staying light tonight that's good
and then winds shouldn't be a problem
tomorrow
and it will be warmer 72 degrees our
high that's going to feel real nice
mild and nice tomorrow this is where we
should be 65
for a high neighborhood by neighbor
temperatures a lot of 70's here
74 for green valley sunrise manor nellis
73 north las vegas
71 mountains edge and 70 for centennial
hills a little cooler for someone at 69
but still not bad
71 for oliante 70 for prim 70 also
boulder city
laughlin close to 80 degrees tomorrow
nice 85
out in death valley so the wind on
wednesday that will signify the change
and once that cold front passes through
those north winds will usher in cooler
air so we go from 72 tomorrow
to 60 on thursday while our numbers will
warm up a little bit this weekend though
it's going to be windy again on
saturday we'll see a slight cool down in
the mid 60s
for next week that is your most accurate
weather update denise back over here